hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt wir waren heute wieder in
unserem garten haben dieses mal
blaubeeren also heidelbeeren gepflückt
und wir haben uns gedacht
oder ich hab mir besser gesagt gedacht
dass ich heute bei muffins machte sich
so ein richtiger klassiker auch viel in
den usa gemacht und heute werde ich mit
euch diese wunderbaren blau bei muffins
in diesem tulpen förmchen machen und wir
schon sehen könnt sind die ziemlich groß
das heißt ich habe jetzt diese tulpen
förmchen aus unserem shop benutzt aber
wenn er die nicht habt können die
natürlich auch in ganz normalen muffin
förmchen machen aber ich finde es so
richtig perfekt von der größe her und
natürlich wunderschön in diesem tollen
farben
wenn ihr also wissen wollt wie ich diese
muffins gemacht habt dann geht einfach
jetzt mit mir in die küche ich zeige
euch nämlich wie das geht
ihr braucht 200 gramm zucker 300
milliliter buttermilch 60 milliliter öl
350 gramm mehl
ich habe jetzt hier einen esslöffel
zitronenschale eine prise vanille einen
teelöffel natron zwei teelöffel
backpulver und eine prise salz und
natürlich 200 gramm
heidelberg ihr könnt natürlich auch
andere bären nehmen
und ich habe auch später noch ein paar
heidelbeeren genommen für oben drauf
zuerst gehe ich jetzt die eier in einer
schüssel und lasse mit dem zucker
richtig schön cremig verrühren
anschließend kommt jetzt die trockenen
und die flüssigen zutaten mit dazu also
mailen backpulver tonnen salz vanille
zitronenschale und natürlich buttermilch
und es wird jetzt einfach ganz kurz
berührt bis alles vermengt ist
in der zwischenzeit habe ich schon mal
meine form mit dem papier förmchen
ausgelegt das ist eine packung mit zwölf
stück und das sind immer zwei pro farbe
drin und ich finde die farbe sind
richtig schön sommerlich und sehen auch
richtig toll aus jetzt können noch die
heidelbeeren unter den teig gehoben
werden
und dann gebe ich einen großen löffel
teig pro förmchen hinein
ich habe jetzt natürlich einen sehr
großen löffel genommen also das waren so
etwa zwei bis drei esslöffel teig das
sind wirklich große förmchen und hab
dann noch jeweils pro förmchen 23
heidelberg mit drauf gegeben
einfach damit war auch von außen sieht
das es halte berner fans sind und diese
dürfen dann bei 190 grad für etwa 25
minuten gebacken werden und sie sind
dann fertig wenn bei der stäbchen probe
nichts mehr am zahnstocher hängen bleibt
dann dürft ihr die muffins aus dem ofen
herausnehmen und ich habe sie dann auch
direkt aus den förmchen herausgehoben
das geht ja ganz praktisch weil man sich
so die finger nicht verbrennt und
einfach die förmchen an den ecken halten
kann und so die förmchen und die muffins
einfach auskühlen lassen kann
so sehen die fertigen muffin sitz aus
und ihr könnt ihr auch sehen
wir haben nur ganz leicht durch
gefährdet weil der teig einfach nicht so
fertig ist und die formen des einfach
selber nicht zulassen also das schon
richtig tolles portieren und jetzt gibst
du mir kurz dabei jetzt könnt ihr
nämlich wenn ihr möchtet noch ein
bisschen puderzucker darüber schreiben
denn ich würde jetzt auch gar kein bus
mehr oder ein top gegner machen ich
finde dass sie so richtig schön groß
sind und es müssen einfach mal fit
bleiben
salz darf so ein bisschen puderzucker
nehmen mit der eingeben und schon ein
bisschen mehr sein
seine zu sparsam oder sogar das reicht
bei dir ich glaube es reicht schon noch
ein bisschen diese jetzt bei uns noch
ganz leicht war
aber wir werden jetzt trotzdem sofort
probieren welche farbe sollen wir
probieren
welche fahrer ist das den zucker
abgeschreckt und probier mal den muffin
zum papa ich mach das jetzt einfach mal
auch um das euch zu zeigen und ihr könnt
ihr mal sehen wie wunderbar flockig und
luftig die muffins sind und total saftig
durch die blaubeeren bitteschön
total lecker könnte man natürlich auch
mit himbeer machen oder mit kirschen
oder mit anderen früchten
aber natürlich sind die blaubeurer
muffins so die klassiker
ich wünsche euch auf jeden fall ganz
viel spaß beim nachmachen
wenn er diese muffins nicht in diesen
toten cupcakes macht dann müsst ihr
natürlich bedenken dass ihr etwas
weniger teig benutzt und ihr dann
vielmehr muffins erhalten das ist etwa
die doppelte menge
und das rezept gibt es natürlich auf
sell list orten welt.de
wenn euch das video gefallen hat würde
ich mich darüber freuen wenn ihn ein
kommentator last und meine bewertung
gibt und natürlich mein video teilt ich
freue mich schon aufs nächste mal wieder
bis bald